excuse me Miss Piggy yes I asked you for  20 adorable photos of Jennifer Warnes  yes so what are these much better  why Thursday's on my least favorite day  of the week yeah see you later Dutch  cook hey animal  hey the shutter on this is actually a  little weird do you think you could pick  it from appreciated here comes mr.  McCain morning Ralph  well good morning Kevin Kevin  oh yeah we're like this so do you guys  worked on oh wait what are you working  on Mariah Carey's feet all right we need  eight reasons auntie those are super  weird go super long noses a creepy  coffees Oh a wake-up link what  that's weird right drinking this yes it  burned the research are you on Facebook  right now oh no no one what makes you  say I'm working yeah yeah when I'm the  boss you're gonna be the first to go  what's coming up